[Musica]
trenta chilometri al secondo
1800 km al minuto
108 mila chilometri l'ora
questa è la velocità con cui la terra
ruota intorno al sole
1668 chilometri l'ora e la velocità di
rotazione della terra sul proprio asse
fortunato a 10 anni e un futuro segnato
come lo hanno tutti i suoi compagni di
scuola e gli abitanti del luogo dove
abita pianura è un quartiere della
periferia occidentale di napoli e negli
anni ottanta gli anni dell'infanzia di
fortunato pianura è soprannominato il
far west
la camorra in quel periodo raggiunge
l'apice del suo potere grazie
all'accaparramento dei finanziamenti per
la ricostruzione del dopo terremoto
e gli ultimi baluardi di una vita
contadina vengono velocemente sepolti
sotto colate di cemento e il sangue dei
morti ammazzati
ma non è solo la camorra a condizionare
la vita di fortunata
la sua famiglia gravata dalla povertà
che in quegli anni di profonde mutazioni
sociali e sentita come una muta
sono gli anni dell'affermazione
dell'edonismo come valore di vita
del tutto intorno a te delle cascate di
gettoni d'oro
fortunato vive in due stanze buie al
piano terra di una palazzina fatiscente
di cinque piani col padre salvatore che
ha appena perso il lavoro
con sua madre annamaria
una donna con pochi anni e troppi figli
donna matilde
perennemente in lutto e soffocata dal
rancore
tre fratelli castrese mauro e adriano e
un quinto in arrivo carlo
con queste premesse un ragazzino della
sua età a due destini possibile essere
sopraffatto dalla miseria e dalla
violenza
o impugnare
una pistola
un giorno tornando da scuola
fortunato s'imbatte nel cadavere di
spider man
un ladro di appartamenti e caduto
dall'impalcatura dove si è arrampicato
nella piazza sottostante la piccola
folla radunata assiste attonita
l'ennesima tragedia della miseria
quell'evento però scatena in lui domande
alle quali diventa urgente rispondere
in piazza sopraggiunge un califfo né con
tre minorenni a bordo uno di questi e
nasi e cana un compagno di scuola di
fortunato
i tre sembrano aver trovato le loro
risposte e le ostentano con un
comportamento da bossi per loro spider
man è solo un perdente
la sua morte è ridicola e ciò che merita
fortunato allora si rende conto che
anche lui morirà da fesso come spider
man se non trova la forza di somigliare
a quei tre balordi o di trovare una via
d'uscita alla tensione che l'opprime tra
le mura domestiche tra le strade
circondate da palazzi fatti dal cemento
depotenziato della camorra
fin da bambino quindi
fortunato si è dovuto chiedere chi fosse
e quale forma avrebbe dato alla sua vita
di fronte al cadavere di spider man con
le ossa rotte è immerso in una pozza di
sangue osservando i volti feroci dei
suoi coetanei inghiottiti dalla violenza
fortunato sente per la prima volta il
bisogno di dare alla sua vita un
significato diverso
il suo destino
si compirà lontano dalla sua terra
si tratta di timidi frammenti di un
futuro ancora confuso fumoso ma i quali
si aggrappa con tutte le sue forze
quei sogni
non possono essere solo una fuga dalla
realtà
devono avere un senso
a pianura però
soprattutto se sei povero
essere bambini o sognatori uno stigma
e proprio una sigla ricordare a
fortunato dopo aver rotto la faccia un
suo compagno di scuola che chi è nato
tondo non può morire quadrata
la maestra giulia tuttavia sa che i
sogni di quel bambino possono diventare
viaggi il ragazzino ha talento canta
bene e anche se in quel momento riesce
solo immaginare di diventare un cantante
neomelodico
come quegli artisti delle emittenti
regionali che venivano trattati da veri
e propri divi
giulia coltiva le aspirazioni del
bambino offrendogli altri orizzonti
l'immagine sul sussidiario dell'orma di
neil armstrong fa breccia nelle fantasie
di fortunato anche lui potrebbe
raggiungere la luna lasciare pianura
ma questo significherebbe esporsi
all'angoscia di una rottura dolorosa
il ragazzino cominciò a tenere un diario
segreto in cui parla con se stesso si fa
domande a borsa risposte annota le sue
giornate tratteggia i volti i gesti le
emozioni dei suoi familiari delle
persone che lo circondano
apre un cantiere nella sua anima e
valuta gli strumenti a disposizione per
realizzare il sogno della sua vita da
libero sfogo alla fantasia è un corpo
d'inchiostro alle sue aspirazioni
e forse su quelle pagine
che getta i semi del suo viaggio
della sua odissea
la situazione economica della famiglia
intanto si aggrava e fortunato è
costretto a lavorare di pomeriggio per
portare i soldi a casa e questa la
condizione per continuare a studiare i
suoi sogni si impattano sempre più
aspramente con le esigenze concrete
della sopravvivenza economica e
psicologica in quel quartiere
dopo le insistenze della maestra giulia
salvatore annamaria portano il ragazzino
a fare un provino per tombolino un
programma da noro per bambini molto
seguito
per partecipare a quella trasmissione
però bisogna comprare un enciclopedia da
700.000 lire
e la famiglia non può concedersi
la decana ragiona
per sopravvivere nel far west
bisogna rinunciare ai sogni
ho un ricordo
ancora vivo della mia infanzia
trascorsa a pianura
non sono i fatti di sangue
la violenza la povertà ad essere rimasti
però indelebili
devo al bambino che sono stato e alle
persone che ha avuto la fortuna di
incontrare
la capacità di filtrare quel mondo
attraverso lo strumento della fantasia
della creatività
del mito
ho capito poi da adulto che il ricorso a
quello stratagemma non è stata solo una
fuga da frutto del pensiero magico
tipico dei bambini ma un processo di
identificazione attraverso il quale
penetrare la realtà e i suoi significati
più profondi
di quel mondo grigio rimane me e forse
sarà così per sempre sapore della
malinconia
ma anche il bisogno di riscatto la
tenacia la forza per reinventare il
mondo che solo i bambini sanno vera
rimangono
i volti cupi l'angoscia la paura la
rabbia di chi avvelena la sua vita e non
sa quello che sta facendo
mentre prendeva forma il futuro a cui
tutti andavamo incontro che spuntava già
dagli scaffali dei primi centri
commerciali nei quiz con premi milionari
nelle prime prove di colore tv gran
parte della gente di provincia come lui
era condannata a guardare senza poter
toccare
gli anni 80
in poco tempo
avrebbero dato forma e contenuto al
mondo contemporaneo segnato dalla
pulsione all'avere prima ancora che
all'essere
in fin dei conti il seme della violenza
si alimenta di frustrazioni
fortunato però fa di pianura e di quegli
anni un palcoscenico su cui far
convivere il sogno e la realtà più cruda
le province del meridione ancora oggi
sono luoghi in cui le vicende umane
vanno in scena senza filtri senza
sovrastrutture narrative sono
osservatori privilegiati sulla salute
morale intellettuale ed etica di tutta
la società
le malattie del mondo
dilagano senza tregua nelle province e
le vittime privilegiate sono oltre alle
donne i bambini
in quei luoghi essere bambini è
pericoloso si rischia di essere
sopraffatti
schiacciati distrutti
allora fin dall'infanzia
si comincia a imitare gli adulti che
come in guerra devono schivare
pallottole per sopravvivere sono le
pallottole della malavita della povertà
alcuni decidono di
non essere bersagli
e allora impugnano armi per essere
sicuri di potersi difendere e colpire
fortunato però deciso di dare una
possibilità ai suoi sogni ha creduto
sentito ho sperato che fuori dalle mura
del suo quartiere ci fosse una
possibilità di riscatto
decide quindi di partire
di essere straniero
nella propria terra
se oggi a 50 anni mi guardo indietro
vedo ancora con chiarezza il bambino che
sono stato
riesco a provare quello che provava a
vedere quello che vedeva e sento ancora
forte il richiamo al viaggio che ha
cambiato la sua esistenza
il vero talento di fortunato forse è
stato quello di aver sempre percepito se
stesso come un uomo
un essere universale che non viene
definito solo
dalle condizioni in cui è nato
quelle sono circostanze secondaria
il bambino che sono stato ha sentito il
bisogno fin da subito proprio tra quelle
strade di violenza di morte di entrare
in contatto diretto con la vera natura
del mistero che lo abitava allora
intuito che era vero che viveva in
provincia ma in provincia di se stesso
prima ancora che di un luogo fisico
una volta
durante una seduta di meditazione ho
avuto un'esperienza molto forte che ha
confermato il sentire del bambino mi
sono reso conto mentre ero rilassato
di essere osservato
non l'ho capito subito è stato come
vedere per caso qualcosa nella coda
dell'occhio
mentre i miei sensi la mia attenzione
dei concetti
allentavano la presa sul reale c'era la
presenza
in un angolo
di questo osservatore di cui vi parlo
per un istante
un solo breve istante
sono riuscito a posare lo sguardo su di
lui
ero io stesso
ho visto me nel futuro nel presente nel
passato
una presenza
che univa in un solo momento il mio
percorso nel tempo
ero io mutato in quello che da sempre
sono ero e sarò
ho sorriso quando mi sono riconosciuto
poi tutto è svanito e sono tornato a
solcare il mare della vita quotidiana
quella esperienza però ha segnato per
sempre la mia identità
da quel momento ho saputo che fortunato
bambino era tenuto per mano fin da
piccolo dall'adulto che sarebbe
diventato come la sua destra 50 anni del
loro per mano dell uomo al di là del
tempo e dello spazio
che mi attende alla fine del viaggio e
che sta mutando con me in quello che da
sempre
1668 chilometri l'ora invece la velocità
di rotazione della terra sul proprio
asse misurata all'equatore il punto più
distante di qualsiasi altro punto sulla
superficie terrestre rispetto all'asse
di rotazione
da che l'uomo esiste
è un viaggiatore che lo vogliono che ne
sia consapevole o meno
la nostra connessione ordinaria è
indissolubilmente legata al tema del
viaggio e della trasformazione
mentre conducevamo le nostre vite nella
cronaca del quotidiano viaggiamo su un
vascello di roccia acqua aria fuoco
spazio che si muove in continuazione a
velocità elevatissima nel vuoto
la cosa sorprendente che non molti sanno
è che proprio come una nave in mezzo al
mare la terra non viaggia sempre la
stessa velocità il suo percorso infatti
condizionato da una serie di fattori che
ne mutano significativamente la
progressione anche se esistono elementi
regolari che agiscono in maniera
prevedibile sulla rotazione del nostro
pianeta come le forze gravitazionali
indotte dal sole dalla luna esistono
attorno sopra e dentro il pianeta forze
che ne influenzano il moto con effetti
rapidi athanor e inaspettati i terremoti
eventi atmosferici le correnti oceaniche
ma anche le attività umane
ridistribuendo le masse attorno al
pianeta alterano l'orientamento
dell'asse di rotazione della terra e la
sua velocità spesso in maniera
imprevedibile
lo scioglimento dei ghiacciai e delle
calo popolari per esempio aumentano la
massa del mare e quindi del pianeta che
è costretto a ridistribuire ai pesi per
trovare un nuovo punto di equilibrio sul
proprio asse che è
una specie di albero maestro del nostro
immaginario vascello finendo addirittura
per ridurre per ora ancora in maniera
impercettibile la durata del giorno
il modo in cui viviamo nel nostro
microcosmo quindi ha ripercussioni
dirette sul macrocosmo che abitiamo
l'odissea
tema di questo tende poema attribuito a
un erode narra del mitico viaggio di
ulisse dopo la fine della guerra di
[ __ ] forse non è altro che un allegoria
della nostra reale condizione della
condizione umana come ulisse l'uomo è in
viaggio
con il suo vascello la terra in rotta
verso una meta epica ma di che tipo di
viaggio si tratta
l'odissea viene definita da molti
critici il problema del ritorno
il corpo centrale dell'opera infatti è
il racconto che ulisse fa delle sue
avventure delle peripezie avvenute in
mare allo scopo di tornare a casa
ulisse odisseo colui che odia o molto
più probabilmente
nessuno
ritorna a casa affrontando un mare che
conosce ma che muta in continuazione
perché soggetto alle circostanze
il pianeta terra non si muove nello
spazio in maniera rettilinea il suo un
percorso ellittico intorno al sole un
viaggio contraddistinto da continui
ritorni
come il mare che riporta ulisse a itaca
lo spazio tempo che solca la terra pur
essendo sempre lo stesso non è mai
uguale a se stesso nello spazio tempo
esattamente come in mare le circostanze
mutano in continuazione
ulisse per ritrovare la via di casa
la sposa il figlio la sua gente si
concede ai frutti del tempo
alle mutevoli circostanze del suo
quotidiano esistere
ulisse diventa eroe in viaggio
sfida se stesso la sua lussuria la sua
avarizia l'avola l'accidia lira la
tristezza la vanagloria alla superbia
tempra in lui virtù come la fede la
speranza la carità la giustizia la
temperanza la prudenza la fortezza
la meta del suo viaggio
e casa
il centro gravitazionale che tutto
richiama e tutto respingere
un viaggio circolare
intorno a se stesso
quando finalmente giunge a casa la trova
però
mutata la sua avventura non ha cambiato
solo il suo futuro ma anche il suo
passato
la nostalgia del passato coincide allora
con la nostalgia del futuro
gli dei che sussurravano nelle orecchie
di fortunato bambino mentre percorreva
le strade della sua infanzia o in quelle
di ulisse mentre lo richiamavano il
viaggio che lo avrebbe reso eroe
chiedono la partecipazione dell'uomo per
compiere il loro comune destino
il dio che crea l'uomo è dall'uomo
creato
un tragitto circolare in cui ogni punto
è passato e presente e futuro
un tragitto di continue province lungo
il quale ulisse si trasforma in quello
che è sempre stato
io credo che la prossima sfida
dell'essere umano
sarà quella di viaggiare nello spazio
infinito
ma per quel genere di viaggio ci sarà
bisogno di una nuova scienza che potrà
manifestarsi solo dopo una nuova
consapevolezza
la tecnologia di cui avrà bisogno
all'essere umano sarà proprio la
consapevolezza
uno stato capace di congiungere
l'infinito al quotidiano il microcosmo
al macrocosmo allora e solo allora egli
entrerà in armonia con colui che tutto
crea e tutto distrugge in ogni istante e
che diviene infinito
una conquista che non potrà essere solo
intellettuale
ma che coinvolgerà necessariamente le
categorie dello spirito e dell'anima
come strumenti
l'alfa e l'omega
il principio alla fine si congiungeranno
e daranno senso al paradosso della
nostra esistenza
un percorso che richiederà probabilmente
altri ammutinamenti altre illusioni
battaglie sangue guerre
come sta avvenendo nei nostri giorni
altre province altri abbandoni e
ricongiunzioni
avremo bisogno
come accade anche in questi giorni
di tenerci aggrappati durante le
tempeste
aggrappati alle nostre idee le nostre
ideologie le nostre convinzioni e nostre
fedi
finché
le onde
non ci travolgeranno
lasciando cadere in mare alla morra
regole e leggi
convinzioni ancorate un passato che non
esiste più come l'abbiamo lasciato
perché ci attende mutato con noi nel
futuro il paradiso terrestre non esiste
più
se non nel futuro
come era come è e come sempre stato
tra dire e tradizione in fin dei conti
sono concetti che hanno la stessa radice
etimologica
un'impresa questa che richiede roi
capaci di partire di tradire tutto anche
se stesse forse per questo che volesse e
nessuno
solo diventando nessuno si può
accogliere tutto
trenta chilometri al secondo 1800 km al
minuto 108 mila chilometri l'ora questa
è la velocità con cui la terra ruota
intorno al sole
1668 chilometri l'ora e la velocità di
rotazione della terra sul proprio asse
299.792.458 metri al secondo e la
velocità di propagazione di onde
elettromagnetiche di una particella
libera senza massa meglio conosciuta
come velocità della luce nel vuoto la
massima velocità che riusciamo a
percepire se osserviamo lo diverso con
le attuali capacità
810 metri al secondo
e la velocità della 221 veramente la
pallottola di metallo più veloce che
conosciamo ma non ci potrà raggiungere
6 intanto
avremo imparato a viaggiare alla
velocità della nostra anima
nella nostra consapevolezza
qui e ora ora e sempre
adesso è mai l'alfa e l'omega
questa è la velocità
della nostra vera natura
la velocità del nostro viaggio di
ritorno a itaca